from her lips to his arm travis biker
continues to take tatted up to another
level only this time his fiance kourtney
kardashian is adding her signature touch
or should we say signature smooch i love
it over the weekend the drummer got some
important new ink here is the pick that
tattoo artist scott campbell shared on
instagram travis's arm now has a
scorpion that covers the tattoo he got
years ago that was dedicated to his
ex-wife and the mother of his two kids
shanna mochler in case you're wondering
why scorpion well we know the rocker's
birthday is november 14th making his
astrological sign scorpio you know just
some fun and then there are the lips
just one week after proposing to the
pooch founder travis got his fiancee's
lips tattooed on his left bicep court
shared this rendering of her pout which
is now forever etched on her boo i've
seen it all but this isn't the first
time the love birds have made news like
this in may the keeping up with the
kardashians star tattooed i love you on
travis's arm and caption a slideshow of
her work by writing simply quote i
tattoo but before courtney showed off
her new skill her boo made things
permanent in april when he got the
mother of three's name tattooed on his
chest travis proposed to courtney on
october 17th with an opulent display of
candles and roses on a montecito
california beach following the proposal
courtney shared these photos on
instagram and travis son landon posted
this tick tock video inside their
celebration dinner
[Music]
[Music]
the couple started off as long time
friends and neighbors before things
turned romantic in january and although
the paris family members seem thrilled
about them tying the knot a source tells
e.t that scott disick courtney's ex and
the father of her three kids is still
processing the news saying quote scott
is stewing over courtney and travis's
engagement and not happy at all he's
lonely right now and not in a
relationship and is very jealous that
things are working out for courtney
scott would prefer to go back to when
him and courtney were just getting along
as co-parents without anyone else in
their lives romantically whatever
happens happens as for travis and shanna
well easy spoke with her in march just
months after the blink 182 drummer and
reality star went public with their
relationship you know travis and i
haven't been together for almost a
decade and
um you know we co-parent together we're
friends however um you know i don't know
anything about his personal life like
that we're not
um as close like that anymore you know i
mean it's been 10 years he has his own
world going on i kind of have my own
world
do i want him to be happy absolutely i
want him to
um i want him to be happy and you know
she makes him happy i think that's
awesome
you